I slowly drop to my knees and I
[Music]
go welcome back everybody to another
fantastic episode of the careful boys
and make some eye contact oh well we
have Sub in here hey sub brought to you
by Pure Life maybe not there might be I
thought we used to get Kirkland who's
buying these Alex Bro as a resurrection
299 okay
so what is something that you've done or
felt or seen that you wish you could
experience again for the first time
wow for the first time skydiving time
you Skydive You' Sky doed I Sky doed wow
why the first time again though um
because you feel like you have all these
expectations on what skydiving is going
to feel like and then when it happens it
happens so so quickly that you're not
like fully fully present um but I also
feel like I went because I'm terrified
of heights to overcome it correct um and
uh I would just love to have that first
feeling experience of it being that
extreme did you do a couple more times
and then you're like it's not the same
no I've are you scared of height still
or no um to a degree yeah like if I feel
like I'm not in in a controlled
environment or I have safety um like if
I'm crossing a bridge and I'm like 80 ft
High then yeah that's what seems scarier
to you skyd or bungee oh uh bungee
jumping oh for sure I'll never go bungee
jumping bouncing around and [__] I think
could snap and I feel like skydiving you
at least have a a second shoot res
chance of Life yeah Reserve so probably
skydiving damn for the first time for
the first time dude that's a good one we
got to go skydiving probably probably
leaving it in dude that's probably the
thing I would like to experience again
for the first time leaving it in I'm
just joking I'm joking dude that was a
bad joke though I can understand how
that's a serious I've never left it in
dude okay why just leave it in whenever
you
want I wish I could dude you know what I
want to experience for the first time
getting my ass beat by my parents cuz I
got my ass beat so much I forgot when
the first time
was bro leave it a Bart dude I'm like
when was the first time I got my ass
beat I'm like I don't remember just it
it just been I don't think it even hurt
well no it did hurt but it was I think
leading up to it was more scarier than
actually getting it done oh after
hearing the threat like I'm going to who
your ass knowing that you're getting
you're going to get [__] up today I
think that was scarier at least for
me first
time I would say the first time I got
high got the munchies and ate McDonald's
oh that's pretty epic I was amazing it
was like that Half Baked like it was
just and then you just
like yeah and then your friends are like
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah no one's talking
and you're just I'm so hungry now oh my
God and it's just I remember that we
were at the parking lot of
McDonald's [__] high off our [__]
minds just you you know yeah and then
the flavors and then everything that's
going through your head oh yeah and it's
never the same again after that you know
but it's just wild like I do remember
vividly that was the only thing I
remember that that moment though I
remember in McDonald's scared as [__]
cuz they're going to like find who we
are cuz we're High making the order and
then we leave and then we're like oh I
can't wait to eat and we're like yeah
let's just [__] eat right here in the
parking lot yeah my first time was with
Hot Pockets
and like a bag of Fritos and flamin' Hot
Cheetos and I was like [__] that sounds
so good I'm hungry again yeah seriously
oh you know what what's one that I might
want to relive maybe it's not like a top
tier one but I just remember the feeling
of like when you first got your license
and the first time you went driving by
yourself or like with your friends like
cuz at that time you were just so tied
to like having to do everything with
your parents or somebody with a actually
could drive and yeah sense of Freedom
that you get at that age feels like holy
[__] the whole world is in front of me
you know what I mean like that's that's
a pretty cool feeling but also too like
one of the first times I've traveled
like when I when I saw like the first
time I went to Hawaii and I saw like
blue water for the first time that's
crazy first time Hawai is pretty insane
I was like what the [__] is this place
it looks like a postcard everywhere yeah
and like I think for me it's probably
has to relate to travel like I would
love to ref like I would love to feel
that again but the good thing about is
like you probably experienced that at
different spots yeah you going have a
bunch of different first exactly exactly
but like I remember the first time I saw
like like Bali right we stayed at our
cousins You' been to body yeah and and
our cousin's wedding they had they
rented out a whole Villa for like a
hundred bucks each night like [__]
crazy and it was just giant like just
exploring the grounds and just being
there with your family and and and
you're experiencing all this stuff for
the first time you're like what the [__]
is this place you know I can't people
live like this you know um stuff like
that I think was was always very uh it's
very fresh in the brain it's like
magical yeah like it's hard to recreate
that I got to say the [__] first time
I did
xasy I like how all of this is drug
related remember I remember exactly
everything that happened damn I don't
even remember the first time I did exy I
remember the first time it was at Master
Dome I remember mine was a house roll
right so you know when you're this the
first time yeah did you ch into your
pajamas right away we were already in is
thing is that a thing dude you're so
[__] comfortable like dude I'll be
back and all the homies like where the
[__] you going like just trust
[Laughter]
me come back oh [__] just trust me is
hilarious BR when it's the first time
you have H anxiety right cuz you don't
know you don't know how it hits so and
then everybody's like oh it's going to
take like 30 minutes which is the
longest 30 minutes of your life cuz you
just ingested a drug and you're in
college and you think it's not going to
work yeah so you're like is it supposed
to is supposed to hit me BL they're like
Yo dude just relax just chill it'll hit
you when it hits you you'll just I was
like how will I know what will I feel
Rel you'll know the next thing you
know so I'm [__] sitting there and
I'm just waiting time's going by I'm
trying my best to not focus on it I'm
asking again on being an annoying
[__] little virgin is this high
school or college this is in college and
then finally they're like dude just just
chill you'll just know take a breath you
all right fine [__] I'll just wait and
then I remember going out onto the
balcony right and the second I opened
the door to the balcony and right when I
walked through because it was like a
temperature change like I suddenly felt
this entire sensation of my body and I
remember being so confused by it so I
ended up taking a step back into the
house and then a step back out step back
in and people started looking at me
they're
like what's up you feel it and remember
being like I don't know what this is
dude right cuz like it's like a blanket
that's all over you and like yo yo I
think he's feeling you know when
everybody stting to be like hey the new
gu's feeling it right everybody gets
hyped yeah everybody starts getting
hyped no one look at me this is the
[__] funniest thing we close the door
I come back in and I [__] you not this
is the most [__] virgin thing ever I
slowly drop to my knees and I
go and everybody starts coming over
start [__] feeling you up and [__]
and then you're getting a massage was
and then you're just like the love is
intense honestly I feel like I just
released some endorphins right now
talking about it yeah that cuz I can
feel it too yeah same me I can't and
then like and then the homie goes get on
my back and then they [__] and then
you start going like this and and
someone with the glow sticks comes to
your eyes and you're like oh [__] wait
so you never taken have you taky uh
Molly oh you don't know you guys don't
know I'm not saying you should but I
should but I think everyone should
experience once the problem is I did
tell one of my other homies at and then
he was like on an XC binge for like 2
years straight yeah see that's the thing
see I I think if you don't have an
addictive personality I kind of do
though don't just also it's different
today than it was before today
everybody's just taking Molly it's like
Pier MDMA there's no come down and stuff
oh so wait so easy is different than
Molly well back in the day it was it was
like always cut up with other [__] Molly
is supposed to be pure yeah they they
would put that would they would take
what a Molly is and they would mix it
with like speed or heroin or crack or
and I've done it all so when you take
Molly now is is it comparable to ecstasy
or is it like it is but it's way cleaner
there's like no come down so you don't
really feel I want to feel what you feel
before you used to be so high that when
you're off you would be so low now
you're just like this is amazing oh I
see so it's all good yeah now Molly's
lit
yeah say less bro I realized when I took
Molly I didn't didn't Peak hard like you
know when you're like on the
2000s yeah on like orange Teslas you
take that [__] and you can feel the
every part of the music
going it's coming and then you're just
gone and then
like everything about you everything in
the music dude and then your eyes are
just you're like sweating on your homies
but you're like I don't care you're like
Testo made this for
me
people don't know Sandstorm the way we
know
Sandstorm hit you were one with
it especially when you're vibing with
like thousands of people dude and you
guys are you guys are all on the and
everyone's on it yeah like that's a
pretty crazy experience every ex but but
the feeling of it the first time yeah
unlike any other yeah you're right you
don't know what to expect and you think
like is it going to be like that beer I
drink or is it going to be like that
weed I smoke no you get transported well
that's why people get addicted for for
your like reference is because they're
always chasing that first time
experience well dude you get close cuz
the second time just take two of
them that's true that's how you get
[__] up though you start taking
multiple at once yeah I start taking I
think like the people that I knew that
would go to Raves regularly I would
never see that level of like buildup and
excitement to like prepare to go to a
rave oh you [__] get your clo you get
your bracelets and [__] like but it
makes sense because it seems so euphoric
right like when it's the closest thing
to a perfect world no it's like heaven
on Earth like let's say you hated
someone right the [__] person you
hated at work or whatever both of you
guys take it and 30 minutes best [__]
friends you don't give a [__] what Happ
all the [__] yeah everything's
you're [__] like this the whole
[__] night like yo [__] get this
guy like four Gatorade or just four
Gatorade on me you good I'll go get the
Gatorade for you you're like $20 yeah so
that's big baller [__] yeah yeah you
know what I felt like you know in the
first avatar when he plugs in and he
becomes the Avatar right yeah and he can
walk again he's like walking and he's
playing and he's like learning new [__]
I feel like you take that bill and then
you're transported into this [__]
world with a bunch of avatars and you
guys are
[Laughter]
[Music]
like ever listen to that song without
drugs I know right why would you why
would you why would you yeah you would
to think about when you listen to it oh
I I got a comparable
experience this is going to this is
going to blow all you [__] jerks out
of the
water I know I know I got one up on you
the mouth of a shark no dude it's kind
of close when you get a bunch of just
bunch of fresh newborn puppies oh my God
so hold on you lay down and then then
you let them lick your face lay down bro
a that's so wholesome and you have all
these puppies comeing and just kiss you
oh my God and then you play
Sandstorm and you know what's better you
get better than that get some e crush it
and just share it with the p oh I just
like yo can you can you like overdose
from that and die from it a dog
Noy probably of course you can't right
like my friend in high school he was
dropping with his girlfriend at the time
and there were love making and in the
middle of that she died W for real cuz
she she had a weak heart condition no
one knew oh yeah you could definitely OD
on it that's crazy that the
other don't do it would you still bust
first though a why would you ask that
dude why would you go there bring it
back to the puppies they're so wholesome
yo that's crazy what the heck
dude you're [__] wild bro I I'll give
you something wholesome to reel it back
from your disgusting thoughts too real
too real you sex how yeah
duding dude you know what the answer is
dude oh my God the first the first time
we went snorkeling in Hawaii right we
saw all these little creatures Turtles
whatever I lost time time we're probably
out there for a couple hours me Bart and
David we got out of the water and we
looked like imitation crab cuz half of
our body was red yeah and then the other
half is pasty as white like we're we're
super like light so we were just in the
water we didn't realize how many hours
we've been just exposed to the sun oh
[__]
yeah so you want to relive that yeah you
want to do that again want to relive
that that that's just to show you how
good the snorkeling was where we just
lost was it oh that's true I totally
forgot but I have a feeling we went to
like three places at once was that bay
or no it wasn't that no but I feel like
we went to multiple beaches on the same
day and we just started snorkeling and
we saw Turtles and all kinds of crazy
[__] the last time you guys been to
hanama Bay maybe a year ago two years AG
did you see some fish over there yeah
really yeah they were like the
snorkeling spots are great I went I saw
nothing how far out did you go you got
to go away from where all the tourists
are oh really that's where they'll run
away from yeah cuz a lot of but it's sad
because a lot of the coral reef close to
the shore is like kind of dead oh really
screens bro some of the I ever done was
actually in Elo Philippines oh yeah I
heard it's crazy in the Philippines that
[__] looked like the [__] drop off
area in Finding Nemo like everything was
[__] magical and I in Hawaii too and
it's like super beautiful yeah but the
volume of fish was like way higher it
was like amazing what if you're St on
E you'd be like Joe breathing water
honestly hey honestly that pretty that
would be awesome cuz it would feel so
good yeah in a snorkel you have
something to
chew it's your pacifier
dude bro you be dancing with the fishes
and you have waterproof
headphones yo if you could touch a
turtle just touch the turtle ho you're
massaging the turtle and [__] you're the
you're probably there feeling algae
like hey what if the fishes know you're
on it like once you take it what if the
fish they probably come over you start
sucking your toes and stuff dude you
know what though I don't think I've ever
this gu why' you say that during day I
don't think I've ever rolled like in in
daylight do you think it'd be overrated
or underrated I don't know I think my
eyes would done like it does it ruin the
experience I feel like it ruins the
experience well I've done it with Molly
so it's not like about having a crack
out like I need [__] lights and like
over stimulation it's just more like you
feel really good cuz I remember even
being at a rave or like and then you
know you go to the bathroom the
bathrooms are lit and as soon as you're
going
like it's like definitely 10x more
sobering but you still feel good so if
you're not going to try and experience
like this crazy over stimulation and
you're just like yo I want to feel good
still feels good yeah it still feels
good I remember we we went to this one
Warehouse Rave and as soon as we popped
it got broken up by the C
so all of us had to go home so all of us
were pretty like it didn't hit yet and
while we were on the freeway it started
[__] peeking and it felt like Star
Wars dude you know like on that one
movie where it's like you look around is
a war movie by the way and then it's
like lighted yeah the light speed is
like douch and everyone was like in the
back seat just looking
like DCH thinking back now I'm like I'm
we are so lucky we didn't [__] die
cuz the driver was just like all of our
eyes were
like and then we're just seeing the
lights of other cars like [__] [__]
there's no way I could drive if I'm roll
Jo that was pretty good
joke hey any more wholesome first time
experiences wow man you made it all
about drugs dude I was just telling my
truth and you related hella hard okay
mister I'm a [__] imitation crab out
the water okay I have a I have a
wholesome one all right wholesome yes
let's bring it back to I mean the
puppies were wholesome yeah but the
puppies are doing e
too blo in their faces when uh Tao was
first born so when you're first born
comes out and then you immediately fall
in love but if I was on E
though everything goes back to if I was
on e that's how you elevated it holy
[__] so funny
like what
a you got to hold the head you got to
hold the head oh my God the baby you're
dancing with the baby you take the
baby's
pacifer just kidding news careful boys
is a brand just kidding news is the man
of smart people the people of just
kidding news careful boys they are very
smart just kiding news the number one
podcast in the
[Music]
world